[Music]
one of the challenges with firestore is
keeping an accurate count on a document
because you might have multiple clients
competing to update the same value at
the same time firestore has always had a
way to maintain accurate counters in the
form of database transactions but they
require a pretty significant amount of
code just to do something simple like
update a counter fortunately just a
couple weeks ago firestore released a
new tool called increment in today's
quick video you'll learn how increment
can help simplify your code and do
things like data aggregation entirely
from the front end if you're new here
like and subscribe and you can grab the
full source code from fire ship i/o
imagine you're in a situation where you
have a blog post and you want to keep
track of the total number of likes on
that post prior to increment the way we
would handle this is to create a
database transaction where we can read
the current value increment it and then
update the database with the new value
this works perfectly fine but we can now
dramatically simplify the process by
just passing an increment value to
firestore and it will do all the
calculation for us atomically on the
back end you can see in the demo here I
have an increment and decrement button
and when I push these buttons they
either increase or decrease the count by
one and what makes this magical is that
we don't need to know the actual value
of the current count to make this update
let's take a look at how easy this
actually is in the code the first thing
we'll do is make a reference to
firestore and you want to make sure
you're using the latest version of the
SDK because this is a new feature and
that will give you access to field value
increment which is a function that
expects an argument with the value that
you want to increment by for a lot of
simple use cases you can increase your
counter by one where you can decrease it
by passing negative one from there we'll
just make a reference to a document in
the database and we can call update or
set with the merge true option to update
the counter so when you pass the
increment field value to firestore it
will look at the value that currently
exists on that document then perform the
math to update it server-side which
means that your clients can never update
it with the wrong value that's how it
looks in the code but you're not limited
to just using integer values for example
you can pass in floating-point or
decimal values and firestore knows how
to perform those calculations as well
but one of the places i find it most
useful is when it's combined with other
document rights in multiple locations
because it makes it possible to perform
data aggregation entirely from the front
end without using a cloud function one
of the most common requirements is to
get a count
the total number of documents in a
collection now we could just read the
collection every time we need the count
but that doesn't scale very well as far
as your costs are concerned because your
charge per read and you'd be sending a
ton of unnecessary data over the network
for this demo I've created a special
document called stats and it's job is to
keep the total count of the documents in
this collection so every time we click
this button we're performing to rights
we're updating the account on the stats
document and then we're creating a new
document in this collection but we only
want to update the count if we're 100%
sure that that new document has been
added to the collection and we can
easily perform an atomic write on
multiple documents by setting them up as
a firestore batch and the code will set
up a reference to our stats document and
then also a reference to a random
document ID from there we can set up a
batch which gives us a way to perform
multiple writes simultaneously that will
all either succeed or fail together when
dealing with counts it's very important
that they're performed atomically
because if the new document is not
actually created but we still update the
count that we're gonna be left with a
count that's not accurate
after you define a batch you can define
multiple updates on it the first
argument is the reference to the
document and the second argument is the
data you want to update when updating
the stats document we'll want to make
sure to also pass on the merge true
option which will make it a
non-destructive update if we leave this
option out it will just reset the count
every time we run this batch and lastly
we call batch commit to tell firestore
to run these updates as you can see
increment is a very simple tool but one
that can help prevent a lot of
unnecessary complexity in your code I'm
gonna go ahead and wrap things up there
if you want to see more quick videos
like this let me know in the comments
thanks for watching and I will talk to
you soon
[Music]